the day that actually taliban entered
kabul and afghan government officially
collapsed
afghan president ran away i was there i
was there and i was actually running for
my own life i came to the french embassy
where uh you know the
outlet that i was working for
belongs to this country and i uh had an
application there there was a sort of
cows you know in the city everyone was
running you know was running for their
own life no one was no one knew that
what to do
it was around 10 p.m that you know the
people just the rumors started among the
people that taliban have entered kabul
city from the west part of from the west
part of kabul city and i don't know what
happened
that everyone was you know somehow
escaping the west of the kabul and they
were coming toward the center of kabul
and what is important republic so it was
a total totally it was a chaos welcome
to episode 108 of the michaela peterson
podcast this is a shorter episode and
more of a news segment really about
what's been going on in afghanistan
i spoke with zakaria hassani in today's
episode we spoke about the restrictions
put on the people of afghanistan by the
taliban
whether the situation of the taliban
taking over the government was
inevitable
the next best steps if any the history
of the taliban and more
zakaria hassani is an afghanistan-based
journalist who fled the country just
days ago once the taliban overtook kabul
where he was stationed
share this episode if you found it
informative and remember to hit
subscribe if you enjoy this content or
at least learn something
[Music]
zakaria hassani welcome to my podcast
thank you very much
yeah thanks for coming on i've been
following what's been going on in
afghanistan and thought it might be
interesting to talk to somebody
who was there so i guess before we get
started could you give a brief
background about who you are
um i'm zakariya hassanin and afghanistan
afghanistan based journalism
i started my work as a journalist as a
local reporter for one of the
leading tv channels in kabul afghanistan
in 2014
um
i was working with intel uh until may
2017 once in 2015 when the i went for
the first time kundu city in the
north of afghanistan
fell to taliban
taliban uh treated me and
a few a number of my colleagues for you
know for the special coverage and
exclusive coverage of the incident that
we had
and
in 2018 i joined rfi radio france
international
up to a few up to two weeks ago that i
was in kabul
and i was actually covering afghanistan
for rfi
but
right now is about five days that i
moved to paris uh three days actually
three days after kabul
failed to taliban
okay so
what do things look like there like when
you say kabul fell to the taliban what
do things look like on the ground there
right now
well um
the day that actually taliban entered
kabul and the
[Music]
afghan government officially collapsed
afghan president ran away i was there i
was there and i was actually running for
my own life i came to the french embassy
where uh you know the
outlet that i was working for
belongs to this country and i uh had an
application there
so
there was a sort of cows you know in the
city everyone was running you know was
running for their own life no one was no
one knew that what to do
uh
it was around 10 pm that you know the
people just the rumors started among the
people that taliban have entered kabul
city from the west part of from the west
part of
kabul city and i don't know what
happened that everyone was you know
somehow escaping the west of the kabul
and they were coming toward the center
of kabul and what isn't part of the
problem so it was a total totally it was
a chaos and uh
so i i'm sure that you have seen the
footage coming out uh from the kabul
airport so that is a consequences of
that day and that
it can clearly you know gives you a sort
of image that what is going on in kabul
and what's going on totally in
afghanistan so if we talk separately in
about every corner of afghanistan for
example in those areas in remote areas
of afghanistan that now taliban are
controlling or fully controlling them
uh
the group could somehow implement their
restrict rules as they had the same
rules in 1990s
but in terms of kabul that uh more
people are here you know the journalists
are here the international journalists
are here so there are medias there are
channels and ways to you know to
disclose the
uh
tolerance atrocities they somehow you
know avoid themselves of uh avoided
themselves of you know doing the same
thing as they are actually uh you know
doing in the rural areas of afghanistan
so
um
i think
we have gone back to the you know to the
1990s
it is a big setback for afghan people
it's a big
setback for afghanistan
okay so you talked a bit about the
the kind of rule that they have and the
kind of restrictions they put on people
can you just give me a bit more
information about what that looks like
in the past three days i talked to
people on the ground for example we
talked to girls in bamiyan in rural
promise which is an ancient promise that
uh which is home to the
biggest
buddhas of you know buddhas of
afghanistan destroyed 20 years ago by
the taliban we talked to the girls
in bamiyan in other promises like
porosity in kabul
the girls were telling us that they are
not allowed to go out without a men
companions
those who come out of their house
without cowering themselves by hijab or
burka they will be lashed out
so
those who do not have main companion you
know they will they will face some you
know fierce consequences by the group
and
i one of one of my friends in bamyan
also told me that there was a young girl
on the on their farm a group of taliban
you know tallow militants
approached her and they gang raped that
girl uh this is this is something that
our witnesses told him and he somehow
shared their stories with me
again raped her and after that they shot
her
for no reason
so this is a bit of that a bit of a
corner of that story you know there are
i'm sure there are plenty of this sort
of history that you can find across
afghanistan but unfortunately as
access has been limited uh since the
tall one took control of those areas so
right now we receive very few of these
sort of histories but i'm sure if we
talk if you talk to people on the ground
you can find out more about this and the
other part is that when you talk to the
people they somehow is scared of their
own life so that is why they prevent
talking to us they prevent talking to
media to journalists
but what we have found is that taliban
do not allow girls to continue to go to
school or continue studying more than
seven girls
so they are not allowed to go to you
know to go to the universities
musics are banned on the streets you
cannot listen to music as we used to you
know listen to music
on the streets of kabul and other big
cities of afghanistan now it is
prohibited and if you listen uh to music
you will you know you will face concept
you will face consequences
uh so
uh
if you uh if you wear jeans
uh then they will also lash you out they
will also punish you they
just you know they're just in favor of
wearing traditional clothes which we
call that piranha tumbon
uh and also their fighters are wearing
that that is the only clothing wearing
you know that the they are in favor of
that and they like that uh unfortunately
and if you wear
for example uh jeans t-shirts or you
know suit then i don't know what what
they're gonna do with you
okay so in the western media i've seen
some articles come out that are hopeful
that the taliban will be a reasonable
government i saw something from nato
that was like well if you have you know
equal rights for women or something then
maybe we could potentially recognize
your government so is there
what do you think they're doing with
this are they pretend are they putting
on a different face for some of the
media for the western world or like
where's the discrepancy there
well this is something you know that the
the taliban try to
uh impose on people and impose or
somehow impose on the international
community since they captured
afghanistan most of the provinces and
after they entered kabul
uh they
repeatedly tried to uh tell
international community that yeah we are
not the same taliban as we were in 1990s
we have changed we have a different
approach towards women rights towards
human rights toward freedom of
expressions towards you know minorities
but unfortunately i i think this is this
is our strategy you know to give
themselves somehow or to be legitimized
by the international community
uh
but unfortunately what we see on the
ground this
that proves completely the wrong way you
know uh
it somehow contradicted their words with
their action
in kabul city we have seen people uh
that they have been punished they had
their hands been chopped off you know by
the taliban for you know for robbery
uh in other provinces the
robbers or maybe other peoples are being
you know hanged hanged up
um it's all about saying that we have
hanged them up you know because of the
robbery but you know there wasn't any
court at all
uh without the without to be prosecuted
they have been punished you know by the
taliban in some parts of afghanistan
uh in herod province taliban just killed
the families of a journalist uh the
deutsche ballet journalist while he was
escaped you know but uh in order but but
for revenge uh
they went to his house uh searched for
him but when they couldn't find him so
they punished them and by killing their
family members and wanting another one
torturing another one unfortunately
and um
yeah when they said that we have our
approach has changed towards women
rights but on the ground is not the same
they say that woman should wear hijab
should wear burka
so this is the same taliban that was the
same rule that they were preaching in
1990s when they are saying that we are
we have our approaching uh in terms of
minorities no we have heard a few days
ago uh and even yesterday not the day
before yesterday they killed
about six hazard people in bamiyan
for no reason you know the same news the
same report we have received that they
killed some azara people in razny
province which are the minorities the
shiite minorities in afghanistan so in
terms of the education and that
previously there's education were
totally banned now they only allow them
to
go to school up to eight up to seventh
grade but this is you know only to
assault maybe if they take they can if
they've fully take control of the
government and the country you we don't
know what will happen even maybe they
they totally banned girls from going to
school so
i personally haven't seen that change in
taliban that
uh zelma khalid the special
representative of the united states for
afghanistan peace process
were repeatedly trying to you know
trying to
say that taliban have changed they are
not the same as they were in 1990s or
when the taliban themselves saying that
we have changed
and
we have different approach towards you
know
towards the past two new year's values
and achievements that we have achieved
so
what we see on the ground unfortunately
prove it wrong they are not changed they
are the same
okay do you think that this kind of
resurgence was inevitable if the united
states was leaving or is it something
that could have been stopped
it was available you know but it is
something that we have to
give with hours to talk about it but if
i make it very brief
it starts
from the do high agreement that the
united states signed an agreement with
the taliban uh
in doha
this agreement somehow legitimized
taliban on the international level and
uh on the on the you know regional level
following that you know it is the
weakness and the lack of will in the
afghan leadership that unfortunately lit
afghanistan to the point and to the
darkness that unfortunately nowadays we
are going through
uh
united states agreement with the taliban
give taliban legitimate a gift hollow
one you know somehow legitimize taliban
and uh give them legitimation sorry
legitimize them and the the
you know the
lack of will in the afghan leadership
somehow you know brought them inside
afghanistan but beside this i think i
believe that nothing of these things
could happen taliban could not
capture afghanistan could not you know
uh occupy afghanistan because we had a
strong army you know during the past 20
years we had we fortunately could build
and could form an army
but there was i think there was a sort
of you know dirty deal between
i don't know between afghan
afghanistan's leadership and the taliban
and maybe united states
that brought album back to afghanistan
we have heard you know
from the generals from the you know from
the soldiers on the ground that taliban
were capturing if one after another
provincial capital without any fighting
for example
i talked to some generals in
north of afghanistan they told me that
we left the province
four hours before taliban enter our
enter the provincial capital without a
single ballot to be shot
so this shows clearly that there was a
sort of deal between the leadership and
between the taliban on the day that
taliban entered kabul i myself witnessed
this one when i was going throughout my
house in west of kabul and then i came
back to the center of kabul
i saw no police no army you know no
soldiers on the streets of kabul
so kabul was handed over without you
know without without any fight so the
same is sorry the same trip you know
actually
uh or the same thing happened in other
provinces so this story was available
but unfortunately there wasn't any will
okay
okay
let's see
how are you safe talking about this
stuff you said you had to you left to
get out of afghanistan and you're in
paris
so when i was in kabul
did they actually you know taliban
entered kabul they
sent me a trade on my twitter account
that yeah we are coming towards kabul we
have monitored your twitter account for
so long and uh
when we entered kabul you know what to
do with you
so that time i was at the french embassy
and i know i was served
but
after three days three days after color
of kabul fell to taliban i could uh
fortunately i i had the chance to leave
a kabul and now i'm in paris so i feel
myself there but you know still i have
relatives i have family there
that i'm worried about them uh but
this is something that i cannot as a
journalist i cannot you know
keep quiet because those people my
family my relatives other journalists
were already in kabul and they cannot
speak up because of their own safety
which is you know understandable
so
it is my i think it's my duty that i
should i should speak out on behalf of
them
and i should you know face the risk and
face the consequences of that
do you think there's anything like what
what do you think the best steps would
be now does afghanistan need
international support is there anything
that can be done or was this just
simmering for the last 20 years and it
was going to happen at some point
i think international community has
already made its decision you know
if i go back to the weeks ago and months
ago that taliban started the offensive
uh
they started capturing uh afghanistan
one promise after another promises
so
the there wasn't you know any i i
couldn't see any serious and a strong
reaction from the international
community and also from the united
states when taliban for example was
capturing a very key province
there was only a very you know ordinary
statement you could only witness a very
ordinary statement from the
international community which means
that they are they have no problem you
know they have no problem with
uh
a taliban control on afghanistan so
i think that right now that afghanistan
is totally in control of the taliban
i'm not sure that the international
community again come back and start
supporting people of afghanistan because
it's too lit i believe it's too late
right now they're in control of kabul
they are in control of every part of
every part of afghanistan there is only
one province which is panchayat
that the resistant poors have to step up
and they started fighting back taliban
but there is still less hope because you
know they are
dual panchay is surrounded by the
taliban they have no way out
and the only
way that they can receive support is
through you know air corridor which is
very difficult they have to talk with
the regional powers they have to talk
with they know
or negotiate with the international
community but i believe this is this is
too late international community could
you know help the people of afghanistan
uh a few weeks ago even
a week ago that kabul was not the kabul
didn't fall to taliban so now i believe
it's too late unfortunately we lost what
we have achieved in the past 20 years
we lost our army we lost our
infrastructure and now you know uh we
have pushed we have been pushed back to
the 1990s and uh
offsetting this is very difficult
yeah well that's not good
is it possible i read something the
other day and i don't know how much of
what i read online is true but is it
possible for people to leave like are
they letting people out
you know
in the absence of economy and absence of
you know employment
uh in the absence of security
i think this is very difficult to live
keep living there
is you know obvious that there isn't any
suicide attack because in the past it
was taliban who carried out suicide
attacks but these days you know taliban
cannot you know maintain the security in
kabul there are lots of robberies people
are you know uh disguising in taliban
uniform and they are you know stopping
people robbed their belongings they
enter people's house in the name of
taliban and they know they stole
everything the banks it's more than a
week that the banks are closed
uh there uh there are lots of families
who have someone outside of afghanistan
to send them
money but you know western union has you
know has been close in afghanistan there
are no ways to uh you know to
somehow transfer them many
i have i have a friend i have a friend
that yesterday he posted something on
his facebook
you know his economic level his
financial level is so good uh he had an
iphone 12 pro max he just put something
on a post on on his facebook page and
said that because all the banks are
closed i have no money left in my pocket
and in order to feed myself i'm ready to
sell
my iphone 12 pro max anyone who is eager
for any cause i can sell this to him
so this clearly shows that how disparate
people are and how you know
how black
these days are in afghanistan so i
believe it's very difficult for afghan
people to keep you know living like this
there should be a government as soon as
possible and things should be you know
corrected
otherwise people you know all the people
will flee
as we are noticing right now
thousands of people gathered at the
kabul airport thousands more and you
know are fleeing from the borders
towards iran and pakistan so
thousands more already they are you know
already they fled afghanistan
so this means that people of afghanistan
do not want taliban to not want taliban
regime
they
they don't want to be disconnected again
from the world
what's the likelihood of do you think
this is going to get worse like do you
think that they're i mean they're
already in power but
is there going to be any fight back or
is it just they're too strong
i believe i believe taliban is not
a group that could govern afghanistan
and i believe that
a taliban takur of afghanistan is the
start of another crisis could be the
start of another civil war as we are you
know seeing the very
first and earliest sign of that
and panchayat as i said before uh people
started resisting taliban in babylon
province again people have started
resisting by resisting the taliban some
other forces are also joining these
resistant forces in order to you know to
fight the taliban and to take back their
lands because
people cannot live with their ideology
with their rules
and
you know
taliban what what taliban knows is only
about pure allegedly what they say pure
islam but they have their own
interpretation of islam they don't know
about governing they don't know about
you know financial issues they don't
know about how to govern a country how
to you know have an administration how
to have a relationship with
uh you know with the with the world and
with countries so i believe that this is
their start and afghanistan situations
you know can become more you know and
can could be deteriorated and you know
we're gonna we will see you know some
bad days ahead
what's the difference between their
religion and what and i guess the
i don't know i need more information
about like what most people believe who
are in afghanistan and then what they
believe
well
um 90 percent of
are muslim muslims are divided into
shiite and sunni sectarian you know
the majority of afghan people are sunni
and taliban are also
very you know extremist sunni group
militia group
they believe that
whoever all of the same rule that they
follow they are in the circle of you
know islam as they are but those who are
in all somehow preaching or practicing
or following some moderate forms of
islam there are no more muslims and they
are infidels they will be labeled as
infidels as they labeled them in the
1990s for example
most of
minorities in afghanistan most of them
are shiite so they have been killed in
the past because of their religion
because of their belief because of their
ethnicity because of you know uh their
beliefs
so in the past 20 years taliban also
carried out suicide attacks you know
targeted you know uh
high profile attacks on
organizations on centers that actually
you know there were homes or actually
they were serving the hazara people or
shiite people of afghanistan
specifically in kabul
all those you know mosques wedding halls
uh
sports collapse
and maternity war that were targeted
before in kabul all of them you know
belong to
somehow hazora people and shiite people
so this clearly shows that they still
believes that
non-sunni people or non-muslim people we
have some other peoples who believe for
example in others
in other religion that they are the
number of them are you know quite
uh there are quite few
so they believe that
if you follow the same rules as they
follow your muslim otherwise you will be
labeled as infidel and they allow
themselves to remove you and to tell you
okay and so they follow the quran to the
word right like every single part of it
no no
there are some only you know some some
parts of ram they are reading that
reciting that
and they have their own interpretation
of that for example maybe i could have
the same my own interpretation of that
part of ron but they have their own
interpretation they have their you know
that backward interpretation you know
the word is fast changing but taliban
are not changing they have the same idea
the same thinking and the same you know
i believe as they had
20 years ago 30 years ago so they are
not a group to be you know a group to
change they are not a group you know to
have a peaceful life with other peoples
with other beliefs they are not a group
to tolerate you know oppositions so i
believe they have come here
they have a mission and their mission is
to destroy afghanistan
okay when did when did they form
that group well therefore they were
formed in the 1995
when there was a sea world war in
afghanistan
between the different parties in
afghanistan so
official mulamar was you know the first
leader and the founder of taliban group
mulamar was from kandahar city in the
west of afghanistan kandahar city is
actually the birthplace of taliban group
uh at first taliban was supported by the
pakistan by pakistan and some other
regional countries in order to bring
disability in afghanistan
and uh to you know to fight other
parties in afghanistan that each of them
were supported were supported by
different you know countries
so
and
they could you know at first in 1995 uh
they could very you know capture
afghanistan very rapidly
so they could govern afghanistan until
1991 uh that you know
we have seen that what happened in
united states
uh september 11 9 11
and uh
following that taliban attacked
afghanistan and the taliban regime were
collapsed within two months
and there was the northern alliance that
actually with the help of other parties
you know they formed
uh a strong alliance in the north of
afghanistan alongside of the united
states they fought the taliban so
uh what i can tell you about the taliban
is that this is not a taliban group is
not with a with a long history they was
uh if you if you just look at back their
story goes to 25 years ago
uh they were pumped yeah the the taliban
group was formed you know during this
afghanistan
would it aim to bring disability to the
country not they didn't achieve that one
but you know the situation just got
worse
okay
well
is there anything else i should know
about this or that you want to tell
people about the situation in
afghanistan maybe
what news sources could be trusted
um
i think it's quite difficult you know
any journalists that step in inside
afghanistan they are somehow controlled
by the taliban
yeah being oppressed by the taliban so
maybe if there is a journalist inside
afghanistan they are reporting live
reporting to
you know western media outlets
uh you should not handle a person
believe that because you know when you
step inside of inside a city that is
surrounded with militia
with savage militia group you know that
they have no fear of killing you of
course there should be some risk of of
course there should be some precautions
and then you know that the journalists
should you know take care of themselves
they are reporting somehow but you know
what the information that coming out
uh through media they are not hundred
percent you know they're not that sort
of uh information that we should not lie
on them 100 percent
but there are people on the ground that
we can you know for for a clearer image
we can uh keep in touch with them ask
about ask them about what is the real
situation on the ground
uh
so
right now i cannot recommend you know
media outfit and
new sources that we could get our news
from them
uh
and let's see what will happen next
okay well can i direct people to follow
you anywhere on social media
yes yes of course
so what's your what's your twitter
handle you're most active on twitter
right yeah that is site hassani say one
okay got it
well thank you very much for coming on
that was that's horrible that that's
happening
sorry you had to leave that's scary
yeah okay
[Music]
you